chasing dollars instead of chasing
passion um probably the biggest takeaway
I have on this lovely what is it
Thursday month Thursday that's what a
red-eye that's Thursday after giving
three keynotes in the last three days in
Dallas San Fran in LA and it's very
obvious to me that the thing that kept
getting brought up was how do i monetize
how to make money all that stuff that
you always hear when you do
entrepreneurial talks or business talks
and in a day and age where I think way
too many people that have
entrepreneurial skills see opportunities
I see opportunities every day online I'm
like ooh there's a huge plate in this
car market or in this you know flower
market or in this glassware market
chocolate market but these are not my
passions and though I might have the
skills to make a buck or two or four
million it is still fundamentally better
because you get stretched thin I promise
you to go after your passions because
you have the same skill sets and when
you focus on passion you'll be able to
do the one thing that's gonna
differentiate you're different
differentiate yourself from your
competition and that's hustle that's the
work that you're gonna be willing to put
in that the other person isn't because
if you don't love chocolate but you see
money in it you're gonna put in your 7
10 12 hours a day but the person that
might not be as talented as you that
loves it more than you do he's gonna pee
or she's gonna be putting in 22 hours a
day and that's dangerous and it's a
broken business so Jeff the Rose is gone
so if you want to win in this market
the biggest thing that I see a lot of
people doing is they find an adsense
word that pays well or they have a
sponsor so they've already got the
dollars and cents for this niche but
they aren't following their passion more
on why I moved to tumblr in the next
couple of days I hope you enjoyed this
video the passion is the secret sauce
Twitter's not the secret sauce it's a
tool it's like a pair of scissors your
passion that's your differentiator